first on cbs mornings we're joined by
the head coach of the newly named did
you hear it the washington drum roll
please commanders
yeah ron rivera is a head coach the nfl
franchise made the announcement just a
short time ago and this is what the
team's new helmet will look like this is
very cool looking
i like it i like the colors it says
commanders right there in front in 2020
you know the franchise [ __ ] its
longtime name of the redskins many
native american groups as you know said
that that name was hurtful and a
dictionary defined racial slur it's been
known as a washington football team ever
since until today head coach ron rivera
joins us to take us behind the scenes
hey coach rivera we're so excited that
you're here good to see you
really good to see you it's good to see
you gail thank you
so you know you guys had a lot of names
to choose from i know i had nothing at
all to do with this decision you consult
with me about nothing
and so but this was absolutely my first
choice so take us behind the scenes you
had a lot to consider why did you and
your team associated with this
making this decision decide commanders
was the way to go
you know working with the snyders and
with jason for the most part you know we
had got over 30 000 you know people
sending in uh names and trying to get us
to go in their direction and it was very
interesting because you went through it
there were a lot of good possibilities
but there are also other reasons behind
not being able to choose those other
names so when we started going through
the list and they started to bring it
down to a final grouping
the commander stood out the most and it
was kind of interesting to look at the
possibilities with that name so really
excited about you know the fact that we
are really starting a new chapter you
know we're turning a page we're going
forward we're trying to step away from
all the things that have happened in the
past but we're also at the same time i
want to make sure we honor and we honor
what has happened with this football
team in terms of the world championships
and super bowls that they've won
ron what does commanders mean to you and
you know there was a lot of pushback
since you when you announced that you
were going to change the name a lot of
pushback about changing it to begin with
what do you say to the people that are
still as the kids that today say feel in
some kind of way that you made the name
change what's your message to them and
what does commanders mean to you
well you know initially i was one of
those people that because i grew up back
in the day when when when being known as
the washington redskins was you know
what everybody knew and so i was a
[ __ ] fan
i apologize for saying um but when we
started talking about the commanders my
first thought was about leaders you know
and in today's world we seem to have a
lack of true leadership and we need
people to step forward and lead this
country and really help to take us in
the right direction i think it's greater
than just the name of a football team as
much as it's really just something that
we have to look and say you know it's an
opportunity for us to take charge take
command and go forward hey coach how you
doing nate burleson here good to see you
i hope the family is doing well um
you mentioned words like leadership and
culture and you talked about changing
that culture what exactly do you mean
and how do you plan on doing that
well i think the biggest thing about
going forward first of all
congratulations on where you are today
man you're a great inspiration to a lot
of us thank you um is that perfect you
know you're welcome going forward is so
important and and one of the things that
we've done and we've worked on it in in
washington and we've done it
purposefully and and jason wright has
done a tremendous job helping us go in
that direction that is you know we're
trying to be inclusive we're trying to
involve everybody this is not just about
a certain group of people this is about
everybody and i think that's probably
the most important thing you know we
talk about trying to develop a
sustainable winning culture and and you
have to do that by doing what's right
and doing things that you know need to
be done changing the things that need to
be changed and you know in this world
that that's important i mean we've got
to adapt and keep going forward
and not really be judged on what
happened in the past but really about
what we're doing now and what we're
going to do in the future
uh hey coach rivera it's tonya koppel
here uh on the subject of change and
leadership i've got to mention that we
we sat down with brian flores a former
head coach of the dolphins uh earlier
today he's got this new lawsuit alleging
that the league has a pattern of bias
against uh coaches of color i don't
expect you to know all the details of
the lawsuit but does he have a point in
that broader allegation that black
coaches in particular don't get a fair
shake in the league
you know i think there is something to
be looked at that really i think what
brian's doing is really really a brave
thing because again in in this world in
this you know in in what we do we've got
to be willing to open up our eyes and
really decide on merit and you know when
you look at a guy like brian and what
he's accomplished and what he's done
there's a lot of merit there and those
are the types of things that people
should be judged on and things should be
based on and i think that you know if we
really take a step back and look at it
we would we would honestly say there are
some things that we have to look even
deeper into and we've got to make sure
we make the right type of changes so
that things are inclusive that we are
doing the things that are that are right
for us
do you think coach that he still has a
chance at getting a job in the nfl after
following this lawsuit some people are
saying he just committed career suicide
what do you think on that on that score
you know
i hope he he he does because again if
you took what he's accomplished you take
his resume and you put it down on paper
and then you compare it to some of the
other candidates that are going to be
out there that's a pretty impressive
resume and i'm you know i grew up in the
military my father was an army officer
and so you know i grew up under the
guise that people were judged on merit
they're judged on rank and you got your
rank based on what you've done in the
positive things and that's kind of why
i've always looked at it um you know and
when we made some of the hires we made
when i first got to washington you know
i hired jennifer king um you know she
became the first black woman uh to to to
hold a position in the nfl on a coaching
staff and i did it because i knew who
jennifer was i understood just exactly
what she wanted and she got it to me
based on her merit i didn't do this as
as a as a stunt i did this legitimately
because i thought she was somebody who
deserved the opportunity
because of all the internships she had
done with me the work she did when she
went and she was working on a college
football team she did the things you
needed to do and so i think if you judge
people based on those things you're
going to make the right decision
coach you have been in and around this
league for a long time i have to say
this before we get off air um you are
truly truly a great coach but you're an
even better man and i appreciate you
leading the way in so many aspects real
quick tom brady's retiring what comes to
mind
oh thank goodness
you know he really is one of the
all-time greats and and then i i think
he's a guy that you know will go down as
as what they say the goat um he deserves
it but you know it is it's kind of a sad
thing for us in this league at the same
time because he's done so many great
things it brought a lot of joy to a lot
of people um and i think that's why you
play the game is to to try to be the
best and when you get to be the best you
get to go out on your terms and that's
what he's doing so congratulations to
tom brady and coach you know like i said
bengals or rams
bengals or rams
oh wow you know what um the commanders
we'll be right back give us an
opportunity
what did he say i don't know
we're gonna get shut off